winter is coming assuming it can get
here through all the SAP bear and the
maiden fair as the season has been going
on even though I'm really enjoying it
I've been nitpicking little things cuz
book you know I'm a geek we nitpick
actually looking back over the scope of
the show there's never been a single
episode where I've been like you know I
kind of wish I didn't watch that until
now you remember last time I complained
about the new romantic pairing and the
emphasis on romantic love is a driving
motivator for these characters and you
obviously you could see how much that
bothered me well this episode was that
times for I didn't enjoy it I didn't
enjoy watching it and I don't like what
it's doing to the characters setting the
specific people in each of these
pairings aside for a second just a
general idea that there's all these
romantic pairings and that romantic love
is being presented as a driving
motivator for their actions really
bothers me because one thing that I
always loved about the show was that
romantic love was almost never anybody's
primary motivation for doing anything
this is a bit of a pet peeve of mine in
general unless the story is truly
supposed to be about the love of these
two people ninety-nine percent of the
time I would cut the romantic subplots
out of movies and television they drive
me crazy they're they're simply because
it's a trope whenever a movie or a TV
show sticks two people together who have
decent chemistry eventually they're
gonna put them together and it wouldn't
bother me if it was just sex but it's
like and now they're in love and now
they're only gonna care for each other
it's like well you've just you've just
screwed the entire dynamic of what
you've had before because you've changed
what their motivations are and I'm not
saying these characters can't grow and
they can't learn to love other people
but to have it happen on mass all at
once with so many disparate characters
it just feels like a really harsh
gearshift for the series as a whole I'm
hoping what happened was they just took
all these romantic angles and cram them
into this one episode so that they don't
have to clutter up other episodes I'm
hoping that in retrospect this episode
is gonna be like ripping off a bandage
but I'm really afraid of the lasting
reverberations of all of this emphasis
on romance prior to this season really
the only time romantic love was ever a
primer
motivator for anybody was with dinero's
when she tried to bring Khal Drogo back
and that time it worked because we had
seen that love grow over so long a
period of time we really were invested
in it and more to the point she was
young and it was her first love so you
can get okay she's going to go further
than is reasonable for him okay great
but now we've got all these other
parents pretty much all of which were
people who just met or if they didn't
just meet we haven't spent a lot of time
with them up to avoid so it feels like
they haven't been together very long
none of these carry the weight of
Daenerys in college logo and all of them
are just bogging it down and to add
insult to injury for this episode we
have the continued endless torture of
Theon Greyjoy look I've given it a pass
up to this point obviously we
established where he was and the
situation was in the next few times it
came up while it made me a little bit
uncomfortable each time that we showed
him we were given some new information
about his situation about the people who
were jailing him and so forth this time
there is no new information learned
whatsoever and it's a scene that
produces without a doubt the most
gratuitous nudity and gratuitous
violence that the show has ever put out
and given the track record of the show
so far that's saying something there
wasn't a lot that I liked in this
episode I mean the dinero's had a good
bit because it was one of the only
things that wasn't dealing with romance
pretty much everyone else they're just
talking about their devotion in their
love but they're talking about someone
who they used to love somebody actually
uttered the line we will die but first
we will live ah this episode feels like
fanfiction of Game of Thrones I just
hope this doesn't represent a major
shift in these characters because I like
them the way they were and I'm not
saying that these characters can't
change but to have all of them start
doing it for love ah when this show has
been so dynamic it's and deep especially
in terms of characters motivations to
have it ultimately either boiled down or
shift over to something as generic and
abstract as romantic love it just feels
like a massive backslide to something
far more generic than the show has been
up to this point now before I put this
video out there I took a peek online it
seemed like general
census on the show was pretty positive
and I'm left scratching my head so leave
a comment down below am I out of my mind
hey if I am tell me about it we'll talk
and until next time this council is
adjourned